Hallöchen ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's das besondere Video, nämlich die Bayram Torte! Oder auch auf Arabisch:
(H: Sag du's bitte!)
Ich habe es immer noch nicht gelernt! Dieser Buchstabe im Arabischen...Ein...Eid!
(H: Und täglich grüßt das Murmeltier!)
Ich kann's nicht, ich kann's nicht!
Mein Hals ist nicht - mein Gaumen ist nicht gemacht dafür!
(H: Eid, Eid!)
Nochmal?
Eid!
(H: Eid!!!)
Ich kann's nicht!
(H: Oder quack!)
Oh Gott, ich sag einfach auf Kiki-Art Eid Torte! So!
Auf jeden Fall ist ja ist ja bald der Monat Ramadan zu Ende und anschließend wird das Ramadanfest gefeiert.
Und dann mache ich ja jedes Jahr eine hübsche Torte
für alle, die einfach gerne mal was Besonderes backen möchten.
Und ich fange jetzt auch direkt an. Ich hab das Video jetzt so ein bisschen -
also das Rezept ist so ein bisschen einfach gestaltet, ich möchte ja auch, dass ihr es nachmacht!
Ich habe jetzt hier zuallererst eine meiner Lieblingscremes,
die ich gleich noch mit zwei besonderen Zutaten aufpimpen werde.
Hier habe ich meine Schlagsahne in der Rührschüssel, die ist ganz kalt!
Und da gebe ich jetzt Quark und Doppelrahmfrischkäse dazu. Den Doppelrahmfrischkäse
könntet ihr auch ersetzen durch Magerquark.
Ach, durch Magerquark! Durch Mascarpone.
(H: Mascarpone!)
Mascarpone!
(H: Okay!)
Ist euch überlassen,
also ob ihr jetzt Doppelrahmfrischkäse  oder Mascarpone nehmt.
Aber wichtig ist halt: die 2 Zutaten sind sehr fest und die braucht ihr schon für die Creme.
Aber Magerquark lockert das nochmal so ein bisschen auf.
So, ich mache jetzt folgendes: ich gebe einfach alles in die Rührschüssel
zusammen mit Puderzucker und Vanilleextrakt.
Und dann fange ich an das erst langsam und dann immer schneller werdend aufzuschlagen.
So, das ist Quark.
So, Puderzucker für die Süße, Vanilleextrakt für den Geschmack.
So und jetzt erstmal langsam damit es nicht alles überschwappt
und dann immer schneller werdend verrühren.
So oder ihr nehmt ganz einfach den Spritzschutz, wär auch schlau!
Und dann kann auch nichts mehr passieren.
(H: Sehr schlau!)
Nach weniger als 2min ist die Creme soweit fertig, die ist auch sehr sehr fluffig
und sie wird auch im Kühlschrank fest.
Ich habe am Ende - das habt ihr gesehen - ein bisschen Sahnefest einrieseln lassen.
Das hilft einfach, dass es dann im Kühlschrank auch noch stabiler wird, das empfehle ich euch auch.
So und jetzt gebe ich noch frische Früchte rein.
Jetzt haben wir ja gerade Erdbeersaison und Ramadan zusammen, daher unbedingt ausnutzen!
Ich liebe Erdbeeren! Die habe ich jetzt hier geviertelt, die gebe ich jetzt mit zur Creme.
Was ich auch mache - die Idee kam mir gerade - ich gebe die...
diese Lotus Kekse rein, das sind diese Spekulatius-Karamell Kekse.
Also wenn ihr die jetzt nicht habt und Butterkekse nehmt,
dann würde ich jetzt euch ganz ehrlich davon abraten
weil das stelle ich mir wiederum nicht sehr lecker vor, aber Geschmäcker sind ja auch verschieden!
Aber die passen auch mit Erdbeeren gut zusammen. Davon gebe ich jetzt auch so...
ja so ein bisschen, einfach nach Gefühl! 2-3 Esslöffel reichen schon.
So, die Creme ist fertig, das ging auch echt schnell!
Ihr habt's selber gesehen, auch sehr sehr unkompliziert.
Und jetzt habe ich hier meine Biskuitböden. Ihr wisst ich bin kein Fan von endlos langen Videos,
deswegen habe ich die schonmal vorbereitet.
Und ich habe ja auch ein Basic Video, das ist das Video aus Kikis Backschule,
da habe ich euch ja gezeigt wie das funktioniert.
Und ich werde euch auch die ganz genauen Mengenangaben zu allem
in die Videobeschreibung schreiben, auch zu denen Biskuitböden, die ich genommen habe.
Ich werde euch die Backzeit reinschreiben, sodass ihr es ganz easy nachmachen könnt.
Ich hab's heute so gemacht: ich möchte nämlich für mein Design eine sehr hohe Torte haben
und hab jetzt hier meinen Biskuitboden aufgeteilt in zwei 18cm Tortenringen
und dann backt's auch gleichmäßiger als wenn ihr jetzt die Masse einmal komplett reinfüllt,
dann wird's oben trocken und innen vielleicht nicht gar, daher das als Tipp am Rande.
So, jetzt löse ich die einmal, die sind auch schön abgetr - ach abgetrocknet! -
abgekühlt? Genau!
Man merkt ich faste, ich bin noch nicht ganz da!
So, jetzt entferne ich hier einmal den Tortenring und anschließend werde ich jeden Boden
einmal durchschneiden. Ich habe jetzt hier auch nochmal einen Extra Tipp für euch:
Wenn ihr nicht möchtet, dass die Böden oben austrocknen,
dann nehmt ihr euch einfach ein Küchentuch,
einmal unter Wasser halten, auswringen und dann an die Oberfläche legen.
Und dann trocknet euch nichts mehr aus!
(H: Boah, das ist ja mega schlau! Ehrlich, ich bin voll beeindruckt!)
Er ist  wirklich beeindruckt! Und alle anderen so: "Das kannte ich doch schon!"
(H: Ja ich kannte es jetzt nicht, ich find das cool!)
So, als nächstes kommt einfach der Teil, in dem ihr alles schichtet.
Ihr habt gesehen, dass ich meine Böden relativ dick eingeteilt habe.
Ich möchte eine hohe Torte und bei Biskuitböden ist es so: der ist so soft!
Der ist einfach so soft, dass ihr diesen dicken Boden - das wiegt nicht so schwer im Magen.
Es ist nicht so, dass ihr nur Boden habt sondern das Boden-Creme Verhältnis ist perfekt.
Und die Böden sind sehr sehr zart, sehr sehr weich! Ihr merkt schon ich bin am Schwärmen!
(H: Ich find das immer voll süß wenn du sagst "Boden-Creme Verhältnis" !)
Ja,  das ist das Boden-Creme Verhältnis!
So und jetzt - ja ich hab jetzt hier mein Konstrukt, Hamza hasst dieses Wort aber es ist ein Konstrukt!
(H: *gequält* Ein Konstrukt!)
Aber das Konstrukt ist diesmal anders,
ich nehme nämlich keine Tortenplatte Hamza! Ein neues Konstrukt!
Ich habe einfach meine drehbare Tortenplatte, hier habe ich ein Cakeboard untendrunter,
meinen ersten Boden und jetzt kommt meine, meinen - mein XXL Tortenring!
Immer wenn ich faste sind die Videos, da komme ich immer so verwirrt rüber!
(H: Chill, chill!)
Ich bin in Wahrheit nicht verwirrt!
(H: Ja, du bist sehr verwirrt sogar!)
Neiin! So, ich leg den jetzt einmal drumherum, schön eng spannen...
so!
Und..ach Gott! So!
Dafür ist ein Klemmhebel da, sonst rutscht er wieder raus!
So und jetzt fang ich einfach an zu schichten.
Und ich mache jetzt - ich werde den Boden auch nicht tränken
weil die Creme enthält genug Feuchtigkeit und wenn das dann im Kühlschrank kühlt,
dann zieht die Feuchtigkeit noch mal in die Böden ein und dann habt ihr ein noch softeres Ergebnis!
Softereres Ergebnis!
Und das ist das, was ich meine: Für solche Momente, für diesen Augenblick
habe ich meine XXL Winkelpalette produzieren lassen...
erfunden sage ich mal! Weil so gibt's die  auch noch gar nicht auf dem Markt.
Und da saßen wir echt lange dran, wir haben an alles gedacht!
Materialdicke, ob es nach vorne hin konisch ist oder nicht, ob's vorne spitz ist oder rund!
(H: Die Länge!)
Die Länge, der Griff - alles!
Es ist alles durchdacht! Ich verlinke sie euch in die Infobox,
genauso wie alle anderen Produkte, die ich benutze.
So und jetzt streiche ich das ganz einfach glatt.
So, oben angekommen könnt ihr entweder die Spezialpalette 2.0 nehmen
oder ihr schnappt euch die Streichpalette, das geht natürlich auch!
Und ich fühl mich gerade so ein bisschen wie so ein Make-Up Artist.
Und dann nehmt ihr die Huda Beauty Palette, die Farbe 2.0, also so weiß ich nicht!
(H: Mascara!)
Ja also ihr seht, im Backbereich gibt's auch so einiges!
(H: Concealer!)
Concealer? Kennst du?!
(H: Mehr kenne ich nicht! Highlighter kenn ich auch!)
Highlighter, also das kennst du schonmal!
Nicht schlecht! So und jetzt gebe ich euch noch einen Tipp:
den Abschluss macht ihr am besten mit dem Boden.
Also dass ihr so einen geraden Abschluss habt und nicht die ungerade Seite oben.
Wobei die Böden sind schon sehr gerade durch das Schneiden
aber es ist immer noch so ein Extratipp beim Backen, dass man den Boden
ganz oben nach vorne drauf gibt.
So und jetzt mache ich es so: Ich hab mir Buttercreme vorbereitet, auch dazu gibt es ein Basic Rezept.
Und ich werde jetzt die Oberfläche ganz dünn mit Buttercreme einstreichen -
das Video ist in der Infobox verlinkt - einfach aus dem Grund damit's nicht austrocknet.
Damit ihr - genau, damit's geschützt ist und danach gebe ich es für 20min in den Kühlschrank.
So, die Torte konnte jetzt schön durchkühlen und jetzt brauchen wir irgendwas zur Stabilisation.
Ihr wisst ja dass wenn Torten sehr hoch sind, sie zum Kippen neigen können.
Das klingt jetzt dramatischer als es ist.
Ich hab jetzt hier so Tortenröhren zum Stabilisieren,
die nehme ich eigentlich wenn ich zweistöckige Torten mache aber ich bin ganz ehrlich:
die braucht ihr eigentlich nicht. Ihr könnt auch Schaschlikspieße nehmen,
ganz einfache Schaschlikspieße.
Aber ich habe keine mehr da, deswegen nehme ich jetzt die
und steck 3 Stück davon rein, die müssen auch nicht perfekt abgeschnitten werden
weil wie gesagt es kommt ja keine zweite Etage oben drauf.
Deswegen machen wir es nur zum Stabilisieren.
Phew! Phew, phew!
(H: Ist das dein Ernst?)
Ja! Ich fordere dich zum Kampf auf! En garde!
(H: *mit hoher Stimme* En garde!)
En garde!
Also als nächstes werden wir mit meinem
XXL Tortenringmesser den Tortenring entfernen.
Ihr wisst ja ich stand vor diesem Problem bei meinem Fault Line cake,
da habe ich auch eine hohe Torte gemacht -
Ich liebe hohe Torten! - ich stand vor dem Problem, dass ich die Torte
nicht aus dem Tortenring befreien konnte.
Wie schlimm ist das wenn ihr alles bis hierhin macht und dann denkt ihr euch so:
Okay, wie kriege ich die jetzt raus ohne dass sie mir an den Seiten bricht oder reißt?
Dafür habe ich mein XXL Torten - ja, Tortenringmesser entwickelt und werde das jetzt lösen!
Das war jetzt -
(H: Das ist eine Neuheit auch!)
Das ist eine Neuheit! Also das kann man jetzt auch als Werbung deklarieren.
Aber ich glaube ihr seid mir nicht böse weil das ist ja mein eigenes Produkt!
So jetzt einmal mit der dünnen Klinge rein, die andere Seite hält das noch mal fest.
So und dann einmal entlang...
Und ihr habt gesagt: "Kiki, sei nicht so bescheiden!"
Das Ding gibt's echt nirgends, es war halt meine Idee.
Ich hab das Problem halt erkannt und deswegen muss man schon sagen:
es ist schon echt ein geiles Produkt!
(H: Hammer!)
Das gibt's auch nur bei uns! Wir sind die Macher!
(H: Googlet es, ihr werdet es nicht finden!)
Genau googlet es, ihr werdet es nicht finden. Ihr werdet es aber bei uns finden und das ist ja das Schöne!
Ich verlinke es euch definitiv in die Infobox und jetzt lösen wir einfach mal den Tortenring.
Was wir dann machen: ganz einfach komplett einstreichen mit Buttercreme.
Macht euch da jetzt keinen Stress, wir werden das danach eh noch mal einstreichen,
es muss also nicht ganz so ordentlich sein.
(H: Woow!)
So, steht noch! Steht alles!
(H: Wie 'ne Eins!)
So die Torte habe ich jetzt grob eingestrichen, die sieht auch gar nicht schön aus
aber ich mache mir jetzt keinen Druck weil gleich wird es eh nochmal ordentlich verstrichen.
Jetzt muss die äußere Buttercreme-Schicht fest werden, das dauert so ungefähr
20-25 oder maximal 30min, je nachdem wie kalt euer Kühlschrank eingestellt ist.
Und dann kommt das Besondere und darauf freue ich mich und bin schon sehr gespannt
und ich hoffe es klappt alles! Also bis gleich!
Jetzt ist die äußere Buttercreme-Schicht fest und wir können weitermachen,
ab jetzt wird's sehr spannend!
Also ich möchte jetzt wieder das Motiv der Mondsichel aufgreifen,
das ist ja das symbolische Motiv für den Ramadan und dafür nehmt ihr euch jetzt einen
Ausstecher oder ein Glas, eine Schüssel - irgendwas rundes und zeichnet euch das vor.
Ich find das immer infacher wenn man das mit was rundem macht. Ich zeige euch das jetzt
und dann geben wir Streusel - nicht Streusel! Dann geben wir erst Buttercreme und dann Streusel drauf.
So jetzt habe ich das einmal kühlen lassen für 10min damit auch hier die Streusel richtig schön fest sitzen.
So und jetzt werde ich den Rest meiner Buttercreme färben.
Wir haben gerade diskutiert welche Farbe: Lila oder Blau. Aber ich glaube wir nehmen Blau, ne?
(H: M-hm!)
Wir nehmen Blau, genau. Dann gebe ich einfach ein bisschen
Lebensmittelgelfarbe rein, verrühre das und dann trage ich das einmal rundherum auf.
Und dann müsst ihr natürlich hier darauf aufpassen, dass ihr die Mondsichel schön nachformt.
Ihr könnt euch auch einen Spritzbeutel dafür nehmen, ich glaub das mache ich auch.
So, beim Einstreichen müsst ihr euch viel Zeit nehmen. Macht das ordentlich,
immer wieder hin und her schieben die Buttercreme, es ist ein bisschen tricky
bei der Mondsichel, alles andere geht ja total einfach.
Und ansonsten würde ich euch nochmal den Tipp geben: kühlt das nochmal ordentlich!
Und wenn ihr mögt streicht den Rand der Mondsichel nochmal mit Lebensmittelfarbe ein.
Also noch mal - das gibt noch mal so einen schönen Touch,
das habe ich auch bei meinem ersten Fault Line Cake gemacht
und ich finde das macht das Ganze einfach komplett! So, was ich dann mache:
ich nehme mir mein Goldspray und sprühe nochmal ordentlich drauf, das gibt auch nochmal
so einen sehr sehr schönen Effekt! Ich weiß nicht ob's durch die Kamera so rüberkommt
aber es sieht echt sehr beeindruckend aus.
Und ja, dann fehlt ja eigentlich nur noch die Oberfläche!
Und da hab ich mir überlegt: Ich muss es ja jetzt nicht noch mehr in die Höhe ziehen
mit irgendwelchen Tupfern
sondern ich nehme ganz einfach Früchte! Frische Früchte, die passen einfach immer.
Und dann könnt ihr sie eigentlich auch schon sofort servieren.
Und das ist einfach was so festliches. Das ist einfach festlich!
Innen sehr frisch, sehr locker..natürlich habt ihr außen die Buttercreme
aber es ist ein gutes Zusammenspiel.
(H: Und ein optisch - *stammelt* ein optischer Hingucker!)
Aww, du bist wie ich heute! Du bist heute wie ich!
Ein optischer Hingucker, definitiv! Ihr könnt das Ganze jetzt nachmachen Schritt für Schritt -
(H: Ich muss trinken!)
Ja, es ist auch schon langsam dunkel
und gleich ist Iftar, also gleich dürfen wir auch das Fasten brechen.
Ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag,
hinterlasst diesem Video ein Däumchen nach oben!
Wenn ihr's nicht schon längst getan habt abonniert meinen Kanal, kostenlos natürlich.
Und dann sehen wir uns auch bei meinem nächsten Video!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!